[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
what's the cutest race a baby
black babies oh they're the kids
girls always say black babies you think
asian right i do think asian in a second
very close second see bla girls always
say black babies yeah i oh i've always
thought asian babies are the cutest and
then you know
then they grow up
yeah yeah yeah yeah you could just keep
them that way i understand that but the
thing is is that what you don't realize
is that you look like a baby that you
just
translated
[Laughter]
a blow up baby i'm a blow up baby
like a bike pump
korean penises have purple shading in it
do they really yeah like the sack is
very dark well your sack is very dark no
arsak yours as a people i think i've
seen other google are korean sacks
always dark are korean balls nut sacks
always dark because yours is oddly dark
no it's they're all
i'm not an anomaly no i think you are if
i had if there was a dark sack
competition in korea i wouldn't win it
you get close i would take third third
or fourth that would be you'd be on the
podium you'd place i would probably yeah
i'm dying up here yeah i asked
i asked my agents like is there any i
know it's about the 70s i'm about the
store because i cuz that showcase that
they saw eric griffin i was on that
showcase the only reason you would have
been on wouldn't have been on the show
yeah because you were you'd be perfect
for it uh is because there was no
asian comics in the 70s i know but can
you say this though i'm serious that's
the only reason the bar staff was thai
oh yeah so i even asked that maybe no
because that's not a big enough that's
not a role you wouldn't do that [ __ ] you
didn't get to you wouldn't get to talk
yeah i'd have a lion
no you'd want to be having real life
double whiskey for you know i mean
richard pryor or whatever
you know
double whiskey richard pryor yeah yeah
yeah and the award for best guest star
goes to
bobby lee yeah that looks like you have
a [ __ ] stand up stand up for a second
isn't that look like he has a [ __ ]
cause it's like thick right there that
little bump that's so good do we have a
marker can we sharpie like a [ __ ] yeah i
want to sharpie draw like a little clip
oh my god wait a minute let me get close
because here come here it kind of looks
like you have
like if i just hold on one second if i
just
i'm going gonna send that be like look
at this babe sent me her [ __ ] bro
[Laughter]
well look at that look at that looks
like a [ __ ] yeah it's look the stomach
looks bad though no but i'll just go
just this heavy girl is sending
everybody dms of her naked you know what
i mean he also has a tv show out now
called i'm dying up here with eric
griffin the flat black we've had on the
show
and al madrid and beanbean we had bean
bean in the show too al madrigal
and um i know you don't like when i get
racial
so i
i edit that or what what well i just
said bean bean and i just oh no you can
say bean bean that's poppy fat black and
beans
[Laughter]
yeah yeah yeah and now we have um
the lead are you the lead in the show
well there's many it's an ensemble but
who's number one on the call sheet that
lately melissa leo yeah yeah yeah yeah
girl that won an oscar all right
relax well you asked i've never heard of
her before you never have to what movie
does she do she's from um
yeah who's okay who what number are you
on the call sheet when you see it i'm
not gonna tell you two oh he's two you
have to be two no
top five mm-hmm yeah is eric below you
though
he's so big i don't know where he is
there's a billboard in uh on uh new york
with just him on it one of them it's the
whole building i know
[Laughter]
and it says i said if anyone doesn't
know who you are if they see this guy on
the thing i'm dying up here it looks
like a psa for diabetes
and he got so mad he didn't take me back
he didn't text me back yeah he looks
awful on that [ __ ] building i'd be
out getting a car accident oh my god why
would you want to be korean if i was
gonna change my race
i wouldn't go to korean
japanese at least at first i mean
they're the best
they really aren't the japanese add up
they're not the best the japanese are
the best they're good
they're good who's better japanese or
korean japanese japanese really
she loves anime yeah you're asking i
wonder how many white people want to be
filipino
[Laughter]
i wonder
i would be filipino you okay so if you
had a choice between korean korean and
filipino i'd be filipino why
because the color of their skin is
beautiful look at that brown like it's
brown it's like and yours is like uh
it's beautiful it's not it's angelic
it's it's urine it's hormone it's not
urinating it's urinic it's your
neck
it's your nature look at how gorgeous
their skin tone is it's that it's
beautiful brown skin it's beautiful um i
would easily be filipino over korea for
sure
you play games
like red dead redemption yeah where you
don't like anything of that world if it
was real but you like it in a game
that's every game [ __ ] nut
no yeah if um if i'm playing um skyrim
i don't want to slay a dragon in real
life yes you do
[Laughter]
all asian people are somewhat fascinated
with dragons it's a part of your culture
you guys dancing you guys do dancey
things
you guys this guy yeah
yeah and i would just say this is game
of thrones my culture [ __ ] you white
dude well no no it's a part of your
culture as well but those dragons but
those dragons are a little too a little
too ridiculous
you guys are like you guys you're gonna
see them our dragons have smaller dicks
no no they're just brightly colored
dragons
you guys like bright color dragons right
[Music]
was i molested
not
no
i was never no i was never molested you
act like you were
you have an anger you you act like you
were molested i was molested i know so
we don't have to like at all
what do you mean you're the one who
whips out your dick all the time and
tucks it in your butt and does weird
stuff
molestation signs out of all the white
dudes i know man
like i let you you you're very funny
number one but you i love you i let you
get real racial with me yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's because you know tell me why
i just feel like there is a relationship
that we have that we understand that
i'm i'm superior to you race-wise
and you know what gets me even more mad
i imagine our neighbors
are going that guy's a [ __ ] [ __ ]
because they never hear her right they
just hear me
yelling
and i've never hit her
never never never
yeah you've thought about it though
[Laughter]
so i'm playing i'm playing red dead
redemption yeah video game the new one
the new one yeah it's so good huh so one
of the
little goals is to kill five cougars not
easy with a bow and arrow
finding a cougar is like running into in
real life and eskimo sure let me ask you
something how many eskimos have you ran
into in your whole life honestly zero
exactly
and i have to kill five of them
you have to find them in the game and
kill them yeah and they're very rare
yeah
right yeah i finally have one i've been
looking for three hours got one i i pull
back on my bone arrow right this is
already here sweetie
i turn like this
and i go back to the screen
he had hit my neck the cougar
eyes rolled back and i fall to the
ground and i die and i look and i go
what
and then she starts crying i didn't cry
a little bit you were so upset like i
can't i don't know when to say anything
you know what i mean well okay and i'm
like it wasn't a short youtube video
this is a 16 hour a day game yeah so i
don't know when to interject did you
know that the cougar was there no
yeah but now you know
[Laughter]
look at how [ __ ] great this is i
don't know what year this is from
but this is mtv20
[Music]
when the whole world
that does not offend me
it shouldn't i love it yeah it's not
it's funny if television was like that i
would watch it again but i gotta tell
you yeah okay you're you're saying that
as an asian person it's not offensive to
you but i'm sure other agents are
offended and i'm sure i think this is
radically offensive for black people you
don't think this ooga booga boom oh
you're the ching chong ching ching chong
ching it's [ __ ] not [ __ ] no
because that's what you guys sound like
i bet your money if ian was edwards was
here he he would go and he would go here
i'll tell you
exactly after you played he'd go
that's ridiculous
i know it's ridiculous man y'all crazy
yeah but you know i think if gabriel
iglesias or george lopez saw the mexican
thing that they we would all laugh in
the same room i bet you most black
people wouldn't think that's funny it
probably isn't no that's [ __ ] racist
that's right i just didn't realize that
that was the bone sticking out of their
[ __ ] nose and this was by the way
this is my first acting gig
[Laughter]
no you know what i don't like uh this is
actually something that you i know you
know i don't like it when someone looks
at me
and says to their friend or goes and
goes that's not saying something
and then a friend goes
oh yeah yeah yeah i can hear them do
that yeah right i've had that happen if
any do you have to have that all the
time if anything just come up to me and
just go hey man
whatever say whatever you gotta say and
then leave there's nothing more
uncomfortable than i see someone staring
at my face yeah and going hmm
yeah it's so i've had this before is
that what yeah and then you see their
face go like this
right you're like what did i do no he's
pointing down there he got it from down
there no he got you a gift over there oh
you did what is it
cereal
just get it how do you not know what it
is
how do you not understand this joke that
he george george put this stuff in here
as a bit
he thinks this is there i am
there i am on the box
[Music]
[Laughter]
george good one
very good one like if you harm me
yeah right i'll i'll do something like
passive aggressive yeah like like you
know if i run into somebody that's
harmed me and i'll go hey and hug them
and go great set and then like a week or
a year later
i'll do something behind their back that
affects them you're like a lady that's
like what a lady does
my dad died
my dad died he put me in
yeah his dad is dead guys why don't you
put him in the thing
you know it's funny put him in the thing
is your dad alive
i have two dads
[Laughter]
i have two dads yeah i have two dads um
would you consider um buffey as your dad
who buff eyes who's buff eyes rogan
you think he's my dad yeah is he my dad
you get like a little like you know i
mean
you look at him like your dad kind of
why don't why don't you like rogan
i love him
hmm
interesting
what's so funny what you're doing right
now because obviously i love them well
you called him my dad my daddy like oh i
am president like you don't like him you
love him no
[ __ ] posted that who did he did
ned yes yeah yes but not with all the
stuff cut out that is the very video
from his instagram
i thought someone was trolling he did
that oh he he posted
probably the funniest thing he's posted
it was very funny yeah i don't know if
he was being subversive okay so that's
real yeah okay
i have to talk to him i think i i don't
i don't know him i didn't know if that
was you've never met him never met him
ever no
a guy that i'm friends with and him
have a weird history
yeah this guy joe rogan
who's that they have a weird i don't
know the whole story
i don't know the whole story
but what i was told is
this is just me this is from what i saw
here i've been told
carlos
i've been told carlos and joe
were hanging out yeah
joe
and carlos have extremely similar
briefcases
they went to dinner
and like in a movie
carlos took
joe's briefcase
and walked home with it
and and used the contents inside like it
was his own
everything inside the briefcase
calculator every calculator pencils
notepads clothes
and joe called him out on saying you
stole my briefcase
and everyone got so mad because people
hold briefcases pretty sacred
that's what happened that's what i was
saying wow
that's what i was told did you see the
documentary trials of gabriel fernandez
yet
i don't think i can watch it why because
they beat the [ __ ] out of that kid
they torture him they feed him cat food
which is normal for you guys but they do
all that stuff
they didn't feed him cat food they fed
him cat litter with pee on it
so it's the woman and and it's her son
and it's her boyfriend and they just
torture him why
for shits and giggles i i i know the
real reason why is is because
that they suspect the kid to be gay
oh is that really what why so because
i definitely don't want to watch this is
so gross and sad yeah the boyfriend
admits that he did it doesn't care no he
cares he's on trial and he just he his
defenses i did it but i didn't intend to
kill him
what is that how is that that's insane
that's like saying i need someone to
death but i didn't the logic for me is
is that
every time you brutalize a boy you know
that death could be a consequence a
child by the way not a boy it's an
eight-year-old boy yeah that's a little
little tiny boy right
so
the dude's on trial right and the jury
although the jury is like yeah guilty
given penalty yeah except for juror
number seven a chinese man
oh no
and he this fools is like
i don't know you know
from where i come from i swear to god
you know i don't know if it was intent
to kill because the thing is i don't
know his heart no yes his heart could be
you know dark and evil but and i'm
literally going you ching chong
press the button
i'm literally [ __ ] you know what i
mean yeah oh my god but they finally
flipped them they both got the death
penalty right well yeah i'm pretty sure
one of the jurors goes hey chinchon look
at me
right i don't think they said that yeah
right
we got to get a bigger gong
[Music]
[Music]
you